the XFL when you think about it you
think about that League that Vince
McMahon came out with in 2001 where it
started off had a lot of momentum then
it turned gimmicky
came and resurrected in 2020 went
through a bankruptcy because of the
pandemic and now it's back with a
Powerhouse group you're talking about
red bird capital and Jerry Cardinal
you're talking Danny Garcia and then
you're talking Dwayne Johnson The Rock
right Kenny accept felt exists under
this Powerhouse they already got through
year one in the XFL Championship the
momentum was there now can they sustain
it
Forbes went into detail to find out
looking into the business of the XFL
[Music]
Danny Garcia and The Rock's relationship
you know you're talking about a couple
who was once married now divorced and
there still remain business partners
right and Danny Garcia you have a
Powerhouse woman she was able to help
him build a career for himself and now
here they are business partners aligning
with one of the more interesting Sports
properties in XFL
is a good fit for this particular
project because she has the vision it
was her who made the crazy phone call to
Dwayne Johnson to pitch him on this
we had talked about the league right at
the beginning because we were watching
Vince do it and I was like man I'm
telling you I wish Vince had invited us
in so I spent a period of time doing my
research to say okay what do we got
what's the process what's the numbers
does it look real you know sitting on it
I knew that property I knew what I could
do with that property I knew the brand
architect the storytelling so I had to
get that in my head and then yeah and
then call teaching you don't call Dwayne
Johnson to say you know I have a decent
idea it's got to be big and important
and meaningful for him and life-changing
to the people and that's what this was
when Danny first came to me and said hey
let's buy the XFL I said yes I needed
the XFL because football didn't end on
my terms
I didn't go out
in a blaze of glory big retirement the
NFL was my dream football was going to
be the thing that I was going to be able
to buy my parents their first house
buy my mom anything she wanted and when
that didn't happen it all that crumbled
for me and there was something
psychologically that I realized that I
hadn't dealt with because football
didn't end on my terms that the XFL
wound up giving to me
with the XFL is for Dwayne Johnson is an
opportunity to present opportunities to
those guys who may not get the
opportunity otherwise right that's what
the XFL is to him he's taking it and
wearing it on the sleeve
these players are player 54.
53 men on an NFL roster I was always
number 54. DJ you're good but you're not
good enough
so your dream men's here the the [__]
chip that that put on my shoulder
this is the same chip that these players
have
the thing that made it the easy yes was
ah but wait a second I never had this
shot I wish I had the XFL when I was
coming out of Miami
man this would have been amazing for me
let's do it let's create that League of
opportunity for players
Dwayne Johnson Danny Garcia Jerry Carter
they reformatted they went to the NFL
and they said let's be partners in this
and so you can see the XFL could be a
developmental league for the NFL and if
that's the business then perhaps it can
work this time the NFL was my goal and
dream
and there's an incredible amount of
boundless respect that I have for the
NFL
that first iteration of the XFL the
setup was different
was combative with the XFL that was a
decision that Vince had made at that
time but this time around in this
iteration
we went to New York and we sat with
Roger and Troy Vincent and their Council
and said we come to you with our hat in
hand and we're not looking to compete
there is no competition this is the
league and that's a shield
whether XFL wins or not I'm I personally
I'm always going to protect that Shield
because that was my dream
and so we said we'd love to find a
pathway to partner up here to grow the
game of football because we love the
game of football
that was one of the main anchors
and the differences from that first
iteration early 2000s the XFL to this
one we came to that meeting with a lot
of love and a lot of respect
in Arlington Texas is where the XFL
places their hubs this is a league that
has eight teams and throughout the week
they practice in this Hub in Arlington
it's good from a cost standpoint because
now you don't have teams all over the
place
I had a chance to catch up with Russ
Brandon the president of the XFL we were
able to talk about the business the
overview and what the XFL is planning
not only after year one but in years to
come
to have the opportunity to work with so
many great people on a daily basis
I call it eight spinning plates at one
time down here when we're when we're
rolling during the season I was a
nervous wreck about the logistics you've
got 25 Charters you have buses you have
18 700 athletes in hotels around this
community all your meals all your
workouts
practice team meetings individual
meetings and this is all got to be
seamless at one time
you know the product on the field could
not have been better it could not be
more pleased with how these guys
executed it and that started from when
we hired our coaches back in May of last
year right and you see the roster of
coaches that we have we have over 150
years of NFL player Personnel experience
to get to this point
to be here Saturday night in San Antonio
and watch two great teams with two great
coaches come together
you know I'll be a little bit emotional
I think for a lot of people because
people have put so much into this this
has not been a one-year undertaking
we've been building this for three years
we will continue to be growing we're in
this for a long haul this is a long-term
play now we have staffs in each market
you know business staffs that'll be
engaged in the community year round
we'll have player activation coaching
activations you know I think that our
staff's did a hell of a job this year
quite frankly in the time frame that
they had to work now we've got that
whole calendar year we can focus on that
and we have over 80 players at this
point that are going to the NFL for
different tryouts because eight of our
teams are done and we have two left for
the championship game and that's what we
stand for to provide them that
opportunity if that's what they choose
to do to watch people
chase their dream whatever that may be
that's what this League's about
to tell the story around second
opportunities or first opportunities
there is a uniqueness about it the XFL
is providing that and it does have a
crowd and if you don't believe that just
look at the 20 000 people who showed up
at the Alamo Dome on May 13th for the
2023 XFL championship game again the
first one since 2001 when the XFL was
born
[Music]
at the Alamo Dome you get a sense that
there's a lot of anticipation for this
game a lot of nervousness Dwayne Johnson
shows up Danny Garcia shows up Russ
Brandon is there they have to pull this
off they have to make sure that it's
magnificent they have to make sure that
the fans got what they paid for they
have to make sure that this presentation
which is shown on National Television is
everything that it lived up to be
because they have seasons to worry about
afterwards
look at what one decision created like
one really powerful decision and a whole
bunch of amazing people you know our two
teams and all our athletes are so
passionate about this moment that they
got here everyone's like okay this is
XFL 4.0 this is XFL 1.0 for me you know
we dream about our wedding day and dream
about and having a baby having those
experience but no one can prepare you
for a championship game when you're in a
league
I have been feeling this surreal thing
for some time now ever since we we
bought the XFL but coming to this
particular event championship game we've
completed the season and that was in
itself one of our goals historically
Spring football hasn't worked so my goal
was can we get through this season what
does That season look like so now we're
here championship game uh it's a special
feeling
I think the bed is a crazy bet but not a
bet that you can't win expansion right
now within that single entity is the
name of their game you want to go from
18 to 12 teams they're trying to work
small keep everything cost efficient so
they can build a business that was a
challenge in itself you get through year
one and the rest is sky's the limit
I understand you know the skepticism
because that's always going to be there
but for me we just got a truck through
it and continue to do what we do and and
it'll all shake out how it's meant to
shake out and if we do good if we find
some success if we do some good things
in this first season great we're going
to learn from it and we're going to move
on if we fail then we're going to learn
from it and we're going to move on
thank you